given how pejorative the term is we're
understandably keen to locate snobs
somewhere far from us they are the
people in the newspaper or the ones who
live in the other part of town or went
to the school we didn't go to but it's
nice not to imagine them too near to
home yet that's to deny an obvious
eventualities
snobs may lie closer to us snobs form
couples they have children and we might
be among them however painful the
unvarnished thought we might be the
children of snobs it's a situation it
can be therapeutic to face up to and to
try to make sense of what is a snob it
has little to do with an old-fashioned
love of aristocracy a snob is simply
someone without an independent center of
judgment someone who can only value what
the in group in society happens to
esteem at any point in time snobs
opinions and tastes might be quite sane
or not the key thing is that they aren't
their own snobs cannot tell what to make
of anything until other prestigious
voices have made up their minds for them
there is a particular conundrum that
sets in when snobs have a child how
should they evaluate this new creature
in whom the world has no particular
interest and who cannot Wow or dazzle it
the thing merely sits in its cot
dribbles and screams a lot it cannot do
it can only be the schnapps first
reaction is often to say that they don't
like babies as a generic category it
sounds innocent enough but the distaste
is more fundamental babies are unlikable
first and foremost not because they are
messy and noisy but because they are so
unimpressive in worldly terms at heart
the snob suffers from low self
confidence which is why the incompetence
of their own small child is so galling
threatening to evoke their own sense of
fragility and vulnerability
the baby can't buy or sell a company
star in a movie or even drink neatly
from a cup and it may on this basis
generate panic and fury in its snobbish
carers
fortunately with a little time school
comes along granting snobs the perfect
tool with which to manage their feelings
snobs make it very clear to their
offspring that doing well at school very
well indeed is not merely pleasing or
cautionary it's quite simply essential
life more or less depends on it there
need to be cups prizes trophies and high
scores in pretty much every subject
doing well isn't enough excelling is the
goal if you don't perform you cannot be
loved whether this is directly spelt out
or merely artfully suggested this is the
ideology under which the offspring of
snobs grow up unsurprisingly most
children of snobs do very well at school
and at university and later on in the
job market a feeling that one doesn't
deserve to exist unless one meets the
criteria of worldly success can do
wonders for one's productivity offering
conditional love has a habit of getting
people to meet ones conditions but
that's also why the children of snobs
are uncommonly likely to be on their way
to a nervous breakdown which often sets
in just when most of the worldly boxes
have been ticked the longing that one
should be recognised for being and not
just doing even if one has done quite a
lot is an extremely stubborn part of
human psychology which has a habit of
periodically rearing its head and
creating serious trouble if it keeps
being ignored across a lifetime we may
well be able to meet conditions but we
can't quite forget the desire to be
loved without them simply for being
ourselves in all our original messiness
and confusion through a breakdown by
deliberately sabotaging what we have
achieved in the world we may be trying
to go back and taste a simple condition
'less love that was denied to us in the
early years we're trying at huge cost to
re-experience a missing stage of
development we are tired of decades of
making symbolic offerings under
emotional duress to the ghosts of
emotionally withholding parents it might
be better to sit in hospital for a while
and disappoint everyone the more we
understand the risks we face as children
of snobs the less danger there will be
of having to act out our complaints to
be a child of snobs is a diagnosis like
any other and deserves its own taxonomy
treatment and pathway to health part of
this involves overcoming anger towards
one's carers and realizing that snobs
are not evil merely wounded and worried
as their child one will have to put
extra effort into the delicate task of
finding oneself valuable and worthy
outside of achievement not because of
anything once said or done but just
because one exists which should always
of course have been enough
the joys and sorrows of parenting
promises us a gentle way of staying calm
around one of the most arduous yet
deeply fulfilling jobs in the world
click on the link on screen now to find
out more